welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Emma Zhang an assistant professor of
sociology her research interests lie at
the intersection of health and aging
marriage and family and inequality
professor Zhang is also a quantitative
methodologist she is particularly
interested in developing and evaluating
methods to model trajectories and life
transitions in order to better
understand how demographic and
socio-economic inequalities shaped the
health and well-being of individuals
from life course perspectives her work
has appeared in a number of scholarly
journals including the american journal
of sociology demography and the
International Journal of Epidemiology
today we'll talk with professor Zhang
about the impact of a 2011 Chinese
divorce reform on the well-being of
husbands and wives
welcome professor Zhang thank you for
having me today so let's begin with an
overview of your work tell us about it
yeah so I'm interested in evaluating
Chinese social policies particularly I
like to think about how specific policy
affect men women differently mm-hmm so
in while my recent work I examine the
effective the 2011 Chinese divorced
reform men's and women's well-being so
before talking about this divorce reform
let me start with introducing everybody
with some background knowledge on
Chinese marriage norms and hasi okay so
in Chinese merchant norms men are
considered the heads of the households
so a woman marries into a man's family
and joins the new households the groom's
family is responsible for providing the
family home as a precondition in order
to gain the approval of the breasts
family for marriage okay
as a result men result homes of
have a difficult time finding wealth in
China because of this man shave
tradition Chinese parents typically only
purchased her family homes for their son
before marriage but they don't help
their daughters to purchase family homes
as a result the majority of the family
homes in China
what registered only under the husband's
name so now this is a background now
let's come back to the 2011 Chang city
was reformed I'm interested in so before
2011 the divorce law was generally
modified to follow the pattern of
promoting women's rights in particular
the family home was generally considered
room prop joint property upon D was
mm-hmm however in 2011 the Chinese
Supreme Court changed a by stipulating
that the family home belongs to the
registered owner upon divorce okay so
why did they make that change so before
it was basically a division of property
between the man and the woman and now
it's just that reverts back to just
being the man's property so why did they
make that I would imagine controversial
decision yeah that's a very good
question
so why they would do that um there are
actually full social economic forces
behind this a bigger change first is as
many trans people got richer there was a
strong need to protect personal property
as a result that Chinese Supreme Court
launched its first property law in 2007
second the housing price in China has
been increasing at a rate of 10 percent
per year since the early 2000s so as a
result the husband's birth family
typically has to spend a large portion
of their family wealth to purchase a
home for the sound at the same time the
divorce rate in China has been
increasing dramatically okay so the
husband's birth family increasingly
faced the potential of losing a large
portion of their family wealth which
works out really really unfair
finally social medias like here started
to play a very important role in
supervising government's behaviors
similar court cases resulting in
different court rulings tend to generate
a lot of controversy on the
which subsequently harms the
government's credibility as a result
there was a need for the Chinese
government to have a divorce law that
was simple specific clear and was
consistent with the spirit of the
property law they launched in 2007 as a
result the 2011 chance he was reform was
enacted okay so what led you to want to
look at this phenomenon yes so the June
the progress of gender equality in China
has attracted a lot of attention lately
as China has gotten richer many people
would expect that in an inequality
situation would improve however if they
look at the global gender gap index
published by the World Economic Forum
channel ranks the 46% L in terms of
gender equality in 2006 but has
continued to decline during the past
decade in 2016 China fell all the way
down to the suti first percentile
aggregate statistics also showed that a
change women are disadvantaged compared
to Chinese men in almost all aspects
including income education and political
representation and so on despite these
aggregate statistics relatively few
studies have looked at the micro level
in the inequality or because intro
household in the inequality so this is
really surprising to me because one of
the most important features of the
Chinese society is that it is organized
around family unit so actually in each
regional intra house original inequality
has existed in China for thousands of
years many times people including
Chinese policy makers tend to use this
inequality as some kind of Chinese
tradition rather than a pressing social
issue so according to a survey conducted
by the government in 2006 and then again
in 2010 not only Chinese men but also
changed women increasingly belief men
should take care of things outside the
household whereas women should take care
of things within the household so all
these facts got me to think what is
going on so while I was deciding my
dissertation topic I wanted to do
something related to intra
social inequality so eventually I
focused on intro house of property
rights because the ownership of housing
Landing accounts for 80 percent of
chains household wealth and this 2011
Chinese divorce reform provides a unique
opportunity for me to estimate the
causal effect of intra household
property rights okay so I am curious to
know you had said that prior to this
2011 reform that divorce rates were
increasing and that was probably one of
the reasons why this reform was put into
place so now has there been a chilling
effect on divorce rates have you seen
them go down since that reform was
instituted yeah that's a very good
question actually I look at the wall
street and men's and women's well-being
in terms to divorce rate
you are right for sure this divorce
reform actually decreases demostrate
because now like women they don't dare
to divorce anymore if the divorce
devalues a place to leave right yeah
right okay so what other findings did
you come to in doing this research
yeah so I also have looked at the fact
of this legal change a massive women's
well-being so I found that in the long
term this legal change decreases women's
well-being
however this negative effects on women's
well-being what we can in the long run
because trans Capas figure out a way to
abide by the more traditional Chinese
marriage norm in my image they actually
have some evidence showing that a lot a
large proportion of the chance
households where it's kind of typical
Chinese household where only the husband
name is on the deed they transfer their
property to their children right after
the legal change so this is really
interesting because we don't see this in
any other countries besides transferring
property to their children I'm sorry to
interrupt but why are they doing that do
you think yes so there are several
possibilities first is like oh now like
because the legal changed the woman lost
family home
there there could be three options right
first it could as a wife back to the
deed so that would become normal or
become the original situation or they
could they even transfer the property to
the wife to make the wife happy or they
could transfer the property to the
children or to someone else
mm-hmm but most of them actually choose
to transfer the property to the children
my guess is so there's one possibility
they may think oh now we transfer the
property to the children so if we get
you was nobody will get the property
anymore our children will get it okay so
in this case right either the husband
and all the other wife are concerned
about divorcing mm-hmm which they think
actually is good for the children in the
traditional Chinese wisdom
another possibility is because of the
housing regulation China launched this
policy saying there will be heavy taxes
attached to the second home so if they
transfer their property to their
children early on then it's possible for
the parents to buy a second home I see
right okay so how are you doing the
research or how did you do the research
for the study yeah so I used that
longitudinal
dataset which is national represented
Hill it's called the China family panel
studies so I have around twenty three
thousand individuals in my sample so
these people were interviewed in 2010
first which is one year before the legal
change and then they were followed up in
2012 2014 and 2016 so I have a the
information about them regarding the
property rights and their well-being and
other outcomes before and after the
legal change so treating these Chinese
divorce reform as a natural experiment I
conduct careful analysis using
econometric techniques to estimate a
causal effect of this legal change okay
now you used to term well-being that's
somewhat of a subjective term so how do
you account for that in in your work
right yeah so actually you looked at a
variety of indicators of well-being as
you said well-being is a really broad
term so the traditional measure our
well-being in the literature is actually
subjective well-being so I also have
this measure but a lot of people they
think of just developing could be very
noisy depends on you we are moved to
today and tomorrow so I also look at
other indicators such as your confidence
about future and the hours you spend per
day doing labour market work and hours
you spend per day doing housework and
and also your body would mm-hmm okay so
what do you conclude in your study right
so in the long term I found this
negative effects on women so basically
it shows that it shows a case about how
a similar gender-neutral policy could
have gendered consequences so this
policy seems to be gender neutral from a
legal perspective as a lot of people
have argued I didn't mention
specifically women or men it just
mentioned whoever has his name down on
the deed however as that my study shows
it is not gender neutral in the Chinese
social context
so my findings really highlights the
importance of advancing gender equality
important implications for change policy
matrix is an issue considering the
Equality as important goal when making
when making social policies so moving
forward do you think that reform will
stand or do you think it will revert
possibly to where it had been originally
yes really difficult to say yeah so
because lawmaking process in China is
very different from the process here
also it really depends on like how the
Chinese government think about the
current situation but I there has been a
lot to push back about how this 2011
Chinese divorce divorce reform right
okay and then so for your work are you
going to build upon the study yes so in
this work I look at the effects of the
legal change on married men's and
women's well-being in the in my next
work I'm going to look at how the city
go change affect children in this
household and single women on the
marriage market so these two are very
interesting cases
and some of that preliminary results
shows that single women start to start
to buy property by themself more before
marriage okay
and also they tend to postpone their age
or first marriage
so these possible responses to this
divorce reform interesting and for
children there could be different
directions because their mothers are
definitely worse off because of this
bigger change so if the mother is worse
off they could be worse off as well or
however as we see the patient's parents
started to transfer property to the
children when they were really young
that means that the younger generation
Chinese they they will have like a lot
of valuable property in hand under their
name these will have important
implications to the January in equality
pattern in China okay
fascinating thank you so much for being
here with us and sharing some of your
work thanks so much for having me for
more information about professor Zhang
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you